genome sequencing has now been performed
on quite a number of cancers including
the Tasmanian devil facial tumour
disease when we sequence a genome and
the sequence comes out of the DNA
sequencing machine all we have is really
a string of chemical letters there are
four chemical letters in DNA there a see
G and T so a genome literally when we
look at it on a page is a string of a
C's GS and T's but occasionally what can
happen is a mutation occurs which means
that one chemical letter becomes a
different chemical letter and usually
this has no consequences at all this
actually happens all the time but very
rarely this can occur at an important
place in the DNA which is inside and
gene which can cause that cell to start
dividing abnormally and that's cancer
we've sequence several Tasmanian devil
tumour disease genomes now and our
studies have told us that the cancer has
about 20,000 mutations that have arisen
since the disease has been cancerous the
patterns of these mutations have
indicated that the cancer itself is
relatively stable that despite the fact
that it's spread throughout the devil
population for several decades now the
disease has acquired relatively few
mutations compared to some other human
cancers this is interesting because it
suggests to us that having a relatively
stable genome may provide an advantage
for a counselor to survive long term and
to spread through the population as a
contagious cell line